up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and Happy
Valentine's Day today we are at the
Chris Brown concert and we are going to
be asking the people are these hoes
loyal or not but before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification Bell that way
you're gonna be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way and
let's get started so you guys are here
to see Chris Brown right yes are you
guys big fans absolutely you guys think
it's true what he says that these hoes
ain't loyal I'll think men ain't loyal
but it's true but I'm not a heart attack
it's all right no definitely no
are these hoes loyal yes no she ain't
absolutely not definitely not we're
never at all you I'm loyal I don't know
what you're talking about no
no obviously no that's why we're here
I've been in a couple situations where
I've seen they're not so have you ever
had a loyal girlfriend to the state I'd
have to say a mix of a bit of a bit do
you guys have boyfriends or no no yes
how do I answer that question would you
guys leave your guys if Chris Brown
would marry you tomorrow no no no I
don't have one so yeah if you did have
one would you leave him for him
uh yeah maybe for one night
I'm gone yeah because not even a little
bit these hoes ain't loyal I've got two
children if we could take them on that'd
be great come on man
you guys have boyfriends no no
you guys did have a boyfriend would you
leave him for Chris Brown
no
yes
if you had a boyfriend and Chris Brown
offered to fly you out
Chris Brown offered to fly you out you
would go
most probably how about you if my
boyfriend wasn't watching he's right
there you can't make this up
make sure
and what about you would you go yeah
sorry your boyfriend's gonna go these
hoes ain't loyal right yeah
Miss situation no
problem
we
passed
would you cheat on your boyfriend with
Chris Brown come on yeah would you guys
leave a broke boyfriend for a rich guy
it depends if there was nice or not all
things being equal just money well you
have to extend I know a broke money you
make it values you don't make it do you
think that most women would leave a poor
man for a rich man unfortunately yes I
do say so not the women I choose
hopefully no no no no money's not
everything it can sway a lot of people
but the people I like to associate
myself with I hope not so so let's flip
the rolls right yeah if your boyfriends
came on camera and said that they would
leave for let's say Margot Robbie or a
beautiful actress would you guys
understand at the same time yeah babe
who cheats more men or women oh they're
both Advanced each other nowadays
they're both responding each other what
men listen men oh men for sure why do
you think that because they're just
they're just never had a relationship
but they're all decks facts who do you
guys think cheats more men or women
women why is that probably
with such beautiful men around and I
think they just get this urge to do it
maybe I don't know I don't know women
are hoes
that's a controversial question you know
what I actually think women I think
women as well maybe men and women but
women are slime I think men you guys
know any women personally that have
cheated yes I have not cheated
women get caught no yeah but the truth
always does come out doesn't it
that's cheap I definitely do and she
didn't get caught no no this one I don't
know guys do you know guys that have
cheated oh yeah I always get caught
because they don't know how to hide
things women are more Sly than men
they're more sly
on the down yeah on the side but also
when a woman cheats it has to you have
to have feelings for a boy who cheats
more men or women women men women I mean
I'm a lesbian so I would say women women
are just horrendous people did you ever
date men or no I did back in the day
what's your experience between like
dating men and dating women women are
horrible people honestly like they're
just horrendous what percent of women do
you think are actually loyal see I don't
know if we're talking about Christian
woman I like to say 100 but even then
it's it's rare but Christian women
better than other women
I say you've got different values
different values of priorities if so
then why do they have such a bad
reputation media again again you think
it's the media just making it up no no
it's not making it up of course you're
gonna select a proportion of people and
have you inflated would you say that
Chris Brown is a nice guy or a bad boy I
think he's a bit of both because he's
very romantic and very sexy but in the
same time he's like he will fix you up
he will deal with you if you need to why
do you think the public had such a
Negative outcry with a Chris Brown and
Rihanna situation but not the same
outcry to cardi B when she admitted to
King and robbing men hmm
I'm guessing because he's a guy it's
just more affirmed upon it's not right
but she is what it is I think because
he's a man and his situation was more
public whereas cardi B people had to dig
deep to find out her history and she
never yeah why do you guys think that
Chris Brown was treated as a Public
Enemy after Brianna however cardi B was
given no pushback when she then robbed
men because well it was just yeah
I mean cardi B sings well but
she hasn't been canceled right she's
been fine but Chris Brown his whole
career was ruined for a couple years I
think it was unexpected of him people
thought he was that sweet boy that
wouldn't touch her just wasn't that bad
boy but he actually is that bad boy and
we'll tell her and put her in her place
she was fighting him so they don't talk
about right they didn't talk about him
her actually fighting him right that's
the case and sometimes you know people
men are raised to like deal with women
if they hit them and whatnot you think a
man has a right to hit a woman if if she
hits first I'm in two minds because some
women like to be dealt with rough and
they like to fight with men and they
expect men to hit them back so it's it's
a bit it's a bit of a mixture I believe
if a woman can raise her hand to a man
she should be able to take the lick back
but then at the same time a man should
never put his hand on a woman first
equal rights equal laughs baby why do
you think that they demonized Chris
Brown but they never talked about that
Rihanna hit him too I saw a tweet today
about someone saying that Chris Brown
has actually hit a lot of women even
after that so it's actually very
surprising that a lot of women are
actually here for his concert and all
that was bad I was sad but I still love
him do you think that speak s of women
liking Bad Boys yeah yeah there's a
point where women stop liking the bad
boys and go for the nice guys
why do you think that is it's boring
right now we love a bit of toxicity a
little bit how do you know if it's too
much toxicity
yeah you start turning crazy so in a way
do you like men that are cheaters
because the cheaters are toxic
bad boy a bad boy bad boy always cheats
oh my God come on you think Chris Brown
is loyal to anyone I'm a baby mum shows
women would leave their boyfriends for
Chris Brown yeah yeah
so like women being less loyal than men
yeah but if you asked a man about
someone that they fancied you think
they'd be like you think it'd be equal
then yeah how did you catch your
boyfriend cheating
I didn't catch him we broke up and then
a two days later I had floods of
messages of me that he cheated and yeah
and then he went and told all his
friends but then lied to my voice me
personally he told me himself when you
guys found out about the cheating did
you stay or did you go that's the sticky
situation
so you you guys are already broken up so
you were done did you get back with him
after that
no no not back with him but I've seen
him we were seeing each other for like
six months after that would you say that
women like cheaters because we picked
the ones that she when there's plenty of
guys that don't cheat that we don't want
yes yeah for me not anymore I can't come
in well lucky you how old are you guys
20. we're 21 next week well you when you
were longer you like the bad boys I
haven't found the right boys
there's so many women at this concert
tonight and they don't really seem to
care and I'm not I'm not hating on them
for it I'm just saying it kind of speaks
to that we we like the bad boy a little
bit yeah we do and over time you just
kind of got over it Like It Happened One
typically do women mature and grow out
of it like what age maybe like 20 28 29
28 29 they typically grow out of it
would you agree with that right early
20s I'll say they should by the early
their early 20s so mid-20s you should be
trying to
set all and not go for the bad time do
you think Chris Brown is he a nice guy
or a bad boy bad boy
so probably not
yeah
personally he likes to make it look like
he's a bad boy but he's not he's the
heart he said Happy Valentine's Day oh
my God
because there's 15 000 women here to see
Chris Brown oh yeah nice yeah absolutely
you think most men can get laid easily I
think more women what did you think they
would do it more because they have more
opportunity no they're just fish of
sometimes because we're loyal we're more
low than men yeah why is it so easy for
women to call men dicks but men can't
call women openly
did you know that one in three men are
actually sexless I did not know that do
you think one in three women are sexless
no no I wouldn't buy that logic wouldn't
women be the ones that are the horse no
didn't the only reason we're promiscuous
is that because we're conditioned by
Society to be promiscuous for men and
that's the only reason why we're
promiscuous
how are you gonna blame your decisions
on that like don't you think you should
take accountability for the decisions
you make yeah but how the hell I got
into their head and said but F that guy
right no but still I think I think they
have that they should take a level of
accountability do you think that women
should take a level of accountability if
they use a man for a date no they go out
on a date with a guy and they don't want
anything they don't want to sleep with
them they don't want anything no they
just want to use them for his wallet
should we take accountability for that
well I mean I think that just reflects
when you as a person if you're using
them for their wallet and not for us
you're just over going on a fake date do
you think that women like bad boys
definitely we are like the good men that
often I'm like good men do you like
Chris Brown that's my man is Chris Brown
a nice guy or a bad boy he's a good boy
he's bad very bad do you think women cap
about what they like definitely we do
who do you think's more considerate on
dates men or women I mean you're asking
a lesbian that's not dated men for 10
years but I mean women are just not
considerate people I don't do you guys
think nice guys finish last yes
absolutely so as a lesbian do nice girls
finish last uh yes really so you think
it's the same like when women date women
they prefer the bad girl yeah probably
yeah there's 15 000 women here to see
Chris Brown who is arguably a bad boy
um I don't know everyone lives loves
Chris Brown I'm not gonna lie regardless
of what happened and what he done
because you know what on a day-to-day
basis these women are facing this
you know I mean they they dealing with
men like Chris Brown anyway so you know
they love a bad boy right yeah it just
shows the nice guys finished last right
100 yeah they do